what a weekend a situation has really
blown up involving a DNC speaker who was
the father of Humayun Khan a US Army
captain who was killed in 2004 in the
Iraq war
first the the the sort of controversy
was hey Fox News ignored the speech by
Qasr Khan instead opting to air
commercials during the speech and then
later returning to the DNC in time to
broadcast a song by pop singer Katy
Perry which was right after mr. Khan's
speech that was controversy number one
as a result of the attention that that
God a bunch of people started saying hey
wait a second Kazu Khan was hugely
critical of Donald Trump during his
speech what is Trump think of this first
let me just play for you the critical
part from mr. Khan's speech the best of
America
if it was up to Donald Trump he never
would have been in America Donald Trump
consistently Samir's the character of
Muslims he disrespects other minorities
women judges even his own party
leadership he was to build walls and ban
us from this country
Donald Trump you're asking Americans to
trust you with their future let me ask
you have you even read the United States
Constitution I will
I will gladly lend you my coffee
in this document look for the words look
for the words liberty and equal
protection of law have you ever been to
Arlington Cemetery go look at the graves
of brave Patriots who died defending
United States of America you will see
all faiths genders and ethnicities you
have sacrificed nothing and no one
this was a very very good speech
although I think my analysis is going to
leave both lovers and haters of Trump
upset to some degree and I'm okay with
that so first of all Khan was spot-on in
terms of what he said about Donald Trump
and Trump's reaction has been absolutely
disgusting we knew Trump's character was
a really really ugly thing I mean he did
mock a reporter with a disability in a
very very crude fashion we know it's
totally gross Trump went on ABC this
morning and not this morning but the
program called this morning and he said
the following there was a man named
Keyser Khan speaking at the Democratic
convention his son Captain Humayun Khan
was killed serving in Iraq and he had
some very tough questions for you he
said you wouldn't have even let his son
in America was you know very emotional
and probably look like a nice guy to me
his wife if you look at his wife she was
standing there she had nothing to say
she probably maybe she wasn't allowed to
have anything to say you tell me but
plenty of people have written that yeah
I mean that's sort of below the belt
I'm as critical as anybody about the
anti-woman realities in Muslim countries
believe me I get called an islamaphobe
for pointing out just completely
undeniable uncontroversial realities but
how is that a response it's not really
responding to the content of it which
Trump kind of does a little bit later
and here is where it really goes totally
off the rails here is Donald Trump
saying actually Qasr Khan is wrong he
did make sacrifices he was going on and
it's not good he said you have
sacrificed nothing and no one
well that sounds who wrote that did
Hillary's script writers write it how
did you answer that father what
sacrifice have you made for your country
I think I made a lot of sacrifices I
worked very very hard I've created
thousands and thousands of jobs tens of
thousands of job those are sacrifices oh
sure I think those sacrifices I think
when I can employ thousands and
thousands of people yeah take care of
their education take care of so many
things even in military mean I was very
responsible along with a group of people
for getting the Viet
Memorial built creating jobs is a
sacrifice helping to build a Vietnam War
Memorial by making some phone calls is a
sacrifice
I don't know that Trump knows the
definition of sacrifice although I read
once that Trump had to stay at a hotel
with the really bad minibar and no
on-demand movies whatsoever and he
barely got through it I mean really now
it let's say for a second we grant that
building of Vietnam War Memorial and
creating jobs or sacrifices which they
obviously are not koster Khan was
clearly talking about sacrifices made in
defense of our country and Donald Trump
has made none of those sacrifices as did
Humayun Khan the answer is that there
are no such sacrifices that Donald Trump
made and we know that Trump doesn't
respect members of the military he talks
about the military as an entity he's Pro
military blah blah blah but look at the
instances of disrespecting individual
members of the military we have of
course here Humayun Khan but we also
have his insult of John McCain saying Oh
John McCain is not a hero because he was
captured by the enemy enemies don't are
heroes don't get captured by the enemy
and of course that's absolutely
ridiculous now a lot of Republicans are
not siding the Donald Trump here Senator
John McCain of course made a statement
blasting Donald Trump's comments about
this and saying this is absolutely
absurd he is completely be literally
littling Humayun con sacrifice et cetera
Senator Lindsey Graham Republican from
South Carolina also saying this is going
to a place where we've never gone before
to push back against the families of the
fallen Jeb Bush saying this is
incredibly disrespectful John Kasich
saying the only way anyone should be
talking about gold star parents meaning
parents whose children have been killed
in the line of duty
is with honor and respect however
however and I think this is where where
I will anger some other people in the
audience not everything that Qasr Khan
said during his post speech media tour
made sense the Trump disgusting
absolutely disgusting here however
listen to what mr. Khan said
on CNN about the connection between
Islam and Islamic terror it is our duty
to keep this country our country
beautiful country safe we have always
thought of that way we will continue to
do our part to keep it safe and
beautiful what he cites in the name of
Islam and all that that is not Islam at
all I wish he would have somebody would
have put something in his head that
these are terrorists these are criminals
these folks have nothing to do with
Islam this is not a logical argument
okay and I want to I want to talk this
through now we have to be able to be
adults here and recognize that I am both
a critic of how Donald Trump responded
to this man who great gave a great
speech but also a critic of this last
statement it is not logical to say that
Islam has nothing to do with
self-professed Islamic terror you can
argue that when someone commits terror
in the name of Islam that it is a
perversion of Islam you can argue it's a
misinterpretation of the texts and we
could sort of debate whether that's true
or not and we can explore that right but
to say that there is no connection
between people committing acts of
violence self reportedly in the name of
Islam and Islam requires suspending any
connection to reality and here's the
conflict here's the double standard of
that I want to illuminate you we'll hear
from some that American foreign policy
can have a direct connection is the
cause of this terrorism that we see if
your argument is that you cannot blame
Islam at all for radical Islamic terror
but you can blame u.s. foreign policy
you're sort of using the same flawed
logic right in the same way that you
don't believe others that their terror
is in any way related to Islam you were
imposing that everyone must believe that
it has been caused by American foreign
policy as if there is any objective way
to say a is a cos B is not a cause
full-stop how does an American know that
the terror carried out by Islamic
terrorists around the world
who say they were inspired by Islam
isn't really inspired by that but rather
by the foreign policy of your country
it's incredibly presumptuous it is both
presumptuous and ridiculous actually the
reality as usual is shades of grey right
there are people most Muslims who would
never be inspired to carry out
real-world violence no matter what is in
the Koran and no matter what US foreign
policy is it's unfortunate really when
we hear that Islam has nothing to do
with Islamic terror well it has
something to do maybe with what they
mean is there's no certainty that all
Muslims become terrorists because of
Islam of course who's arguing that right
that that's that's an undeniable reality
but this game that is played where
anyone even self professing that they
were inspired by Islam was not really
inspired by Islam it's incredibly
presumptuous and arrogant to tell other
people that they are wrong in terms of
what inspired them and to impose an
alternative solution we just know they
were inspired by US foreign policy will
says who in what way can you say that
that is definitively true and what they
claim inspired them is not true really
doesn't make any sense so Trump
absolutely disgusting the idea that
Islam has nothing to do with terror
committed under the name of Islam also
makes absolutely no sense two years ago
you might remember this was kind of like
one of the biggest stories on corporate
and independent media every single day
for several weeks Russia made incursions
into Ukraine including this very
controversial annexation of Crimea
roughly 10,000 lives have been lost as a
result of the ongoing violence now you
might expect that the Republican nominee
Donald Trump would have I don't know
some semblance of a working knowledge of
what's going on in Ukraine Trump was on
ABC's this week with George
Stephanopoulos over the weekend and he
was asked about this conflict for if
you're expecting to see anything even
resembling insightful opinion on what's
going on there
forget it it's not even clear that
Donald Trump has a passing awareness of
what the hell was going on
over the last two years in that part of
the world you'll remember
that the Trump campaign pushed a little
bit more of a pro-russia Republican
platform two weeks ago and that's sort
of part of what's building this picture
that Donald Trump may be more connected
to Putin and the Kremlin and Russia then
maybe would be advantageous for him in
terms of the upcoming election and he
was asked about this that was sort of
the context George Stephanopoulos said
hey so you know your campaign you pushed
for a lighter touch when it comes to
Russia in the Republican platform it's
already hilarious just with Trump's
first response take a look energy why
did she soften the GOP platform on
Ukraine I wasn't involved in that yeah I
was not involved in that I'd like to I'd
have to take a look at it but I was not
involved you know what they did they
softened it I heard but I was not
involved so let me see if I get this
straight your campaign speak which
speaks for you presumably the campaign
is a representation of you makes changes
to the Republican it asks for changes to
the Republican platform which softens
the stance on Russia and when you're
asked about it the first thing you said
is I wasn't involved in that at all and
I've only heard in passing that my
campaign which works on behalf of me has
softened so basically you're saying
you're a puppet you're admitting that
you're a puppet you're not even aware of
what it is you're campaigning do you
have a passing knowledge of what your
campaign did your people are doing
things that you're not involved in nor
understand nor seemingly have an
informed opinion on great leadership
from the master at building
organizations right I mean that this is
just ridiculous
now let's continue and this is where it
starts to get even more nutty they took
away the part of the platform calling
for provision of lethal weapons to
Ukraine to defend themselves why is that
a good look you know I have my own ideas
he's not going into Ukraine okay just so
you understand he's not gonna go into
Ukraine all right you can mark it down
you can put it down you can take it in
wait a second Donald you're guaranteeing
us that Putin is not going into Ukraine
oh cool well he's been there for two
years and it was one of the biggest
international news stories for months
so how does Trump get out of this simple
go into a word salad coma reminiscent of
Sarah Palin and that's exactly what he
did
put it down you can take it anyway sorry
there okay well he's there in a certain
way but I'm not there yet Obama there
and frankly that whole part of the world
is a mess under Obama with all the
strength that you're talking about and
all of the power of NATO and all of this
in the meantime he's going away he take
takes Crimea he's sort of by me and she
said you might recognize that I'm gonna
take a look at it but you know the
people here from what I've heard would
rather be with Russia than where they
were is anybody paying attention to the
fact that we have an uninformed
individual uninformed to a degree that
rival Sarah Palin who believed Africa
was a country and counted Alaska's
proximity to Russia as foreign policy
experience Trump is rivaling Sarah
Palin's lack of knowledge the
laughingstock of the last eight years of
the Republican Party Sarah Palin might
know more than Donald Trump about some
of these issues and by the way if you're
trying to make it seem as though you're
not in cahoots with Russia Trump saying
hey the Crimean people might rather be a
part of Russia happens to be the same
line that Russian state media uses and
by the way that referendum that Trump
and Russian media referred to has been
widely discredited as taking place
during a heavily armed occupation by
Russian troops there is nothing at all
about that that was honest fair or legal
and Western leaders have denounced the
entire referendum vote as illegal it's
sort of funny and horrifying that I'm
able to group together the opinion of
Trump and Russian state media that's
what we have right now this is the
situation and the most disturbing thing
I'm not disturbed particularly that you
have people as clueless as Donald Trump
I'm not disturbed or surprised that
people as clueless as Donald Trump are
running for president the the surprise
and the shock is that in spite of
clearly knowing nothing
I mean nothing ladies and gentlemen his
supporters seemed to have unwavering
support for him it is truly truly
disturbing okay I need to talk to you
about something very very serious I
don't know if this is a story about how
delusional or how dangerous the tepee
ticket is that's of course Trump pens
not toilet paper trunk pens Republican
vice-presidential nominee Mike Pence
said late last week that if Donald Trump
is elected roe v wade the landmark
Supreme Court ruling that legalized
abortion would be overturned saying
quote I'm pro-life and I don't apologize
for it
we'll see roe v wade consigned to the
ash heap of history where it belongs now
the point Pence is trying to make is
important and it's one of the reasons
I've been saying Trump needs to be kept
out of the white house at all costs
if roe v wade is going to be overturned
it will be the result of a very very
conservative Supreme Court now how would
the Supreme Court get so conservative
well if Donald Trump becomes president
and named Supreme Court justices from
that extremist lunatic crazy list that
was provided to him by right-wing think
tanks this is what Donald Trump would do
and Mike Pence is reminding us that
elections have huge consequences in
terms of the Supreme Court remember that
in the four years expected to be
governed over by the winner of this
November's presidential election there
could be three or four Supreme Court
justices nominated okay now to be clear
in reality it would be tough even with a
supreme court that is quite conservative
to overturn roe v-- wade in four years
roe v-- wade was decided on due process
grounds you can't just come in and
circumvent that by passing another law
theoretically you would have to pass a
law someone would sue the courts would
strike it down and then when you got all
the way up to the Supreme Court they'd
have to change their minds on the issue
and flip about 50 years of case law okay
but that let's put that aside for a
second because many of trumps ideas are
delusional and not based in reality
the fact that this is even being
discussed as a worthy goal is disgusting
when I say that the Supreme Court is a
hugely important consideration our
viewers sometimes
well I don't care about that I want to
do a protest vote or vote for a third
party or I might stay home people write
to me they say Oh Trump wouldn't be that
crazy with the Supreme Court he's just
pandering whatever can we really take
that chance if they are talking about
overturning roe v-- wade which has been
a part of American society since 1973
everything is on the table and
dangerously so I don't want to hear this
garbage about Oh David you know that
you're being alarmist there's not going
to be that big of a difference on the
Supreme Court if it's Trump or Hillary
you know they're the same on so many
issues now they're actually quite
different on many issues this is a
separate question from as Hillary as
progressive as I want her to be
obviously not I mean no there's no doubt
that the answer is no but I guarantee
you Hillary is not going to pick lunatic
conservatives suggested to her by the
Heritage Foundation or the American
Enterprise Institute I'm sorry it's so
insane I don't remember exactly who it
was at this point that is a practical
and empirical and tangible difference
and if you're even talking about
overturning roe v-- wade as a result of
the the appointments you will make to
the Supreme Court then we are living in
Looney Tunes Cocoa Puffs Ville and this
is the danger that we all need to be
aware of when we think about well maybe
I'll stay home or maybe I'll protest by
writing in my cousin or something like
that no no no no no this is hugely
hugely dangerous what a show today big
big news in the presidential race
the big question post RNC Post DNC was
what would happen in the polls would
Donald Trump's incredible performance on
the last night of the Republican
convention inspire new voters and new
followers and give him an insurmountable
lead over Hillary Clinton or would that
not happen typically there is a
convention bump for both candidates and
the most interesting question is whether
we will end up after the Trump bump and
after the Clinton bump in the exact same
place where we started before the two
conventions and the answer is decidedly
no Hillary Clinton has opened up leads
in seven of eight recent major polls
before we look at all of the polling
data I'll sort of tell you anecdotally
the first one of the first first or
second of these new polls that came out
post-convention was a Reuters poll
Republicans saw it they said oh this
poll is garbage it is drastically
oversampling Democrats by 10 12 %
relative to the proportion that they
actually represent of the electorate it
had Hillary at +5 and Republicans were
going nuts about it for 24 hours until
multiple other polls confirmed equal or
bigger leads for Hillary Clinton so
let's take a look at the numbers this is
the two-way race and as you will see
starting with that Reuters poll near the
bottom of the screen and going up
through an NBC News poll that has
Hillary Clinton at +81
LA Times poll has it at Trump plus two
and otherwise all of the other recent
post-convention polls have given Hillary
Clinton between a three and nine point
lead over Donald Trump nationally and
you will notice the nine-point lead is
the most recent poll that is the CNN orz
poll the average at the bottom of the
screen the average of recent polls from
Real Clear Politics has a four point
four percent lead for Hillary Clinton of
course taking into consideration margins
of error for these polls individually
the fact that we are averaging them what
we can say is it appears as though
Hillary Clinton is consistently somewhat
ahead of Donald Trump now we can
speculate about the reasoning for this
bump a bad RNC Trump insulting a gold
star military family a good DNC whatever
but there are some really really
interesting numbers to look at within
this latest CNN our C poll to pick just
one poll and look at it a little more
closely to see if we can figure out the
internal dynamics of what is driving
this bump for Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton has
made noticeable gains among two
important groups number one independence
and number two Bernie Sanders supporters
let's talk first about those independent
voters Hillary Clinton has gained over
the last week 13 percentage points of
support among independent voters up to
50 percent of independent voters from
only 37% of independent voters
supporting her about 1 week ago and very
very interestingly the Bernie Sanders
support 78 percent support from Bernie
Sanders voters prior to the convention
now up to 91 percent of Bernie Sanders
supporters supporting Hillary Clinton
after the DNC again according to the
most recent CNN RC poll now I want to
show you one more set of numbers what
happens because you might say well David
it's all well and good Hillary Clinton
is up by an average of 4.4 against
Donald Trump but what if you include
Jill Stein and Gary Johnson the green
and libertarian candidates respectively
let's take a look and you will notice no
effect if you look at the Real Clear
Politics average for Hillary Clinton the
lead is unchanged when you pull a four
way poll including Gary Johnson and Jill
Stein is still 4.4 percent now the
difference does tell us something which
is for example the Reuters poll which
had Hillary Clinton plus five when it
was a two-way race has Hillary Clinton
tied with Trump at 37% apiece that poll
is missing a lot of people by allowing a
not sure answer when you force people to
make a choice you get much better
numbers for Hillary Clinton and that is
something that we will continue
following so for those who say that the
picture changes drastically when you
introduce Gary Johnson and Jill Stein it
doesn't how does Nate silver from
fivethirtyeight.com
summarize where we are today pretty
simply saying this is good news for
Hillary Clinton but we still need to
wait a few weeks to see if she can
sustain her bounds before we can say the
race has fundamentally
change now I want to speak now with
peace and love to those who are emailing
me saying David this is over Hillary
Clinton is going to pick up closer and
closer to 100% of Bernie Sanders as
support as we get closer to November 8th
Donald Trump is going to keep saying
insane things insulting people he
shouldn't be insulting Hillary's going
to win in November it's very clear what
is going to happen that is the type of
complacency that loses elections for
Democrats that they should win we've
seen it over and over again if you say
that you're right about one thing which
is yeah there's no sane world in which
this should be a remotely close race and
I'm actually going to do a piece later
this week maybe tomorrow maybe on
Thursday presenting the case that in any
other developed country Donald Trump
would not surpass twenty percent support
I I have data to confirm that for us but
that's that's not today
today what I want to focus in focus in
on is this is not a sane world this is
not a sane situation this is not a sane
Republican primary electorate if you
were going to sit back on your lazy boy
recliner and watch MSNBC or CNN or if
it's for laughs maybe Fox News whatever
your preference is and say oh Hillary
Clinton's got this in the bag that's the
type of attitude that will have Donald
Trump
selecting three to four Supreme Court
justices between 2017 and 2021 and we
cannot risk that so I will present the
polls to you the post-convention
situation is looking better for Hillary
Clinton but this is by no means by no
means a foregone conclusion I have to
play for you some really disgusting
video Mike Pence he is the P part of the
T P ticket Trump Pence held a rally in
support of his and Donald Trump's
candidacy for president this was in
Carson City Nevada yesterday a military
mom stood up wanted to ask a question
and the question was from one military
mom concerned about Donald Trump's
comments about
a military dad Kizer Khan the father of
Huma Yoon Khan the military captain that
was killed that has now become the
subject of so much controversy she
stands up and this is remember that we
support the troops camp this is the Pro
military voters they put the ribbons on
their cars and it's all great and they
love the troops and this military mom
stands up to ask a question about the
comment Donald Trump is made about that
father and that dead soldier and the
room starts to boo
the pro-military room of Trump
supporters boos the military mom take a
look at this
so in his defense Mike Pence has
actually been handling this far better
than Donald Trump he's sort of become
the cleanup guy at this point
do you understand the sickening
ridiculous reality of this the people
who say loudly that they support the
troops here a military mom ask a serious
question about respecting our troops and
they boo that it is absolutely
inconceivable Mike Pence insisted that
his running mate Donald Trump would
stand with the military if elected no
evidence that that would happen he said
I have never spent time with someone
more devoted to the Armed Forces of this
country if Donald Trump is the most
devoted guy to the Armed Forces you've
ever been around there's a real problem
this is the guy who deferred his Vietnam
service repeatedly disrespected former
prisoner of war and military veteran
John McCain did not donate all the money
to veterans that he claimed he did and
hideously disgustingly disrespected the
Khan family real roomful of Patriots
right there shush shouting down booing
the military mom and has anyone noticed
that Mike Pence is sort of the default
cleanup guy now for the Trump campaign
he has to show up and although I'm not
predicting this I wouldn't be shocked if
Mike Pence stepped down as VP he'd
probably be prevented from doing it
because it would look really bad but if
he continues to just have to defend or
reframe absolutely vile comments from
Donald Trump I really don't get where it
is that this is going to go we have
breaking news out of the Middle East we
are now bombing ISIL in Libya with both
armed you
planes and unarmed US drones a quote out
of the region
the first airstrikes were carried out at
specific locations in cert the militants
seized the Mediterranean coastal city of
cert last year it has become their most
important base outside of Syria and Iraq
so these strikes started yesterday they
were authorized by President Obama they
hit an Islamic state tank and two
vehicles that posed a threat to forces
aligned with Libya's GNA this was the
third US air strike against Islamic
state militants in Libya but US
officials are saying that they're not
mincing words here they are saying yes
this is the beginning of a sustained air
strike not just an isolated strike this
was recommended by US Secretary of
Defense ash Carter to President Obama
and he did indeed order these strikes
after that recommendation there is an
estimate I've read two estimates
basically about the number of Isis
Islamic state fighters insert one
estimate said under 1,000 another
estimate said several hundred I guess
that suggests anywhere from three or
four hundred up to nine hundred or so
fighters in this region now a really
interesting question that is coming up
and a few people have emailed me and
tweeted me about this David what's the
legal structure of these strikes is this
a war we've talked about how rarely
there is actually a declaration of war
is this authorized by some kind of prior
action this is absolutely fascinating
Peter Cook who is the Pentagon press
secretary said that the legal
authorization for the cert strikes
actually came from the authorization for
use of military force against the
perpetrators of the 9/11 attacks nearly
15 years ago today this is part of this
structure that we've established where
now this Libyan action is linked to the
authorization of force issued after 9/11
now there's sort of two sides to that
one is this is the problem without
actual
declaring war without actually seeking
that authorization we have this broad
authorization of military force and it
is now being applied nearly 15 years
later to conflicts that seemingly are
disconnected from 911 but there's
another side to that right because if
you consider that the u.s. went into
Iraq based on a faulty intelligence case
no doubt because of the perceived or
supposed connection of Iraq to 9/11 we
now know that wasn't true and if you
then realize that the Islamic state has
risen in the vacuum and instability
created by that hairbrained decision by
george w bush's administration to go
into iraq in the first place there's
actually somewhat of a direct line you
can draw between the authorization of
force after 9/11 and using that to go
after ISIL Isis the Islamic state in
Libya today it's insane because it shows
us the scope and importance and and sort
of significance of these authorizations
to use military force but at the same
time you actually can make a case that
it is related there's another thing I
want to mention here and I've said this
very clearly several times now I soul
Isis the Islamic state - call them what
you like they will be operationally
eradicated in Syria Iraq and Libya
likely within 12 to 18 months we know
how to do that it's relatively
straightforward for militaries at our
level of sophistication that's not going
to solve the problem of Islamic state
extremism and individual acts of terror
like we've been seeing in Europe like
we've been seeing in the United States
like we've been seeing in different
areas I don't know what the solution to
that is we've talked time and again
about this reality that you really can't
stamp out an ideology in the same way
that you can destroy a tank or rockets
or whatever shoulder-mounted RPGs or
whatever weapons a group of radicals may
have there are more and more groups that
believe a community-based approach is
necessary to tackle
the extremist ideologies underlying the
Islamic state and the sort of gist of it
is you support the broader Muslim
community and encourage them to defeat
extremist ideologies from the inside out
by sort of showing that there is no
space for them by showing that they will
not be tolerated and build a moderate
voice to take on the extremist ideology
internally it sounds good right but I
mean it's easier said than done others
say the path forward is you support
secularism and I will I want to speak
very clearly here secularism not atheism
secularism meaning everybody is still
free to practice their religion the
difference being that that religion does
not play a role in the governing power
of states you don't have a religious
influence in the way states are governed
how do you do that in many of these
countries that are the these sort of
main catalysts or
safe havens or places that is the
Islamic state can take up arms and
establish themselves I don't know
practically speaking how you do that it
could be effectively impossible but we
are going in the direction and these
strikes support what I've been saying
now for several months that it is very
very likely that within 12 or at the
most 18 or so months the operational
strongholds of the Islamic state in
Syria Iraq and Libya are not going to be
there but this may only engage even more
of these isolated incidents that we have
been seeing in Europe and in the
Americas I am opening it up to you and
would love to hear from you what your
ideas are in terms of tackling the
ideology and I'll tell you right now if
what you're going to email me and say
you're going to Eve them email me and
say the only problem David is u.s.
foreign policy and that is the lone
catalyst for what we are seeing I reject
that completely in the same way that I
reject completely that merely the
religious teachings of Islam alone are
responsible I don't think either of
approaches really make sense in a world
where you cannot simply draw a direct
line between one action and what we are
seeing in terms of the Islamic state and
and extremism send me your thoughts
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
Donald Trump just doesn't get why if he
were president he couldn't go around
nuking people if he wants we have very
disturbing video of Joe Scarborough on
Morning Joe and MSNBC show disclosing
that he was told that Donald Trump three
times during one session just asked well
why can't we just use nuclear weapons
I'm going to play the clip for you it is
very disturbing and even more disturbing
at the end of the clip you will actually
hear a military expert say you know the
system is designed for whoever is
president to be able to launch nuclear
weapons pretty damn quickly if they make
the decision that they want to take a
look at this several months ago yeah a
foreign policy expert on international
level went to advise Donald Trump and
three times he asked about the use of
nuclear weapons three times he asked at
one point if we have them why can't we
use them right that's one of the reasons
why he has he just doesn't have foreign
policy experts around Trump asked three
times three times in an hour briefing
why can't we use nuclear weapons
with that you go to America and be
careful Republican leaders so general
Hayden the problem is blowing up I want
to ask just one more time and and it may
be classified but the steps Donald Trump
decides to use a nuclear weapon what is
the time frame between his decision and
when the nuclear weapons are launched
Joe it's it's scenario dependent but the
system is designed for speed and
decisiveness it's it's not designed to
debate the decision this is terrifying I
mean this is legitimately terrifying in
a way that we haven't seen since the
collapse of the USSR and the end of the
nuclear arms race there's always a risk
of some rogue state getting a bomb or
figuring out how to make a bomb it's
sort of part of why the Iran deal was
hugely important but an American
president who during a briefing in one
hour is told three times hey here's a
problem that you should be aware of Oh
could we use a nuke there here's a
second problem you should be aware of oh
and what if we just used a nuke to solve
that problem here's a third problem you
should be aware of hmm you know what
sounds like the solution to that problem
nuclear weapons this is effing
horrifying Louis I don't know of any
other way to put it I'm starting to
wonder if Trump even understands have
anything how powerful these weapons are
and what the the effects of these
weapons are maybe he just doesn't even
understand that well he doesn't
understand much so I would stands to
reason he also doesn't even understand
what nuclear weapons are and I know you
and I Rachel have talked about the
reality that Hillary Clinton is not as
left as I would want she's not as left
as you would want but she's not confused
about why we can't just start nuking
people there are relevant differences
between the candidates even on foreign
policy yeah there's a big difference
because she introduced the dirty bomb
Act in 2005 trying to increase security
of radiation sources as opposed to
saying okay let's just take them all out
let's increase everything and this is
gonna be a full-on nuclear war when you
think about President Obama's comment
that Donald Trump is unfit to be the
president when you think about Hillary
Clinton's comment that he is
temperamental II not qualified to be
press
this is their stuff that we're talking
about and I know that I frustrated I
assume you guys do too when people say
they're effectively is no difference
between Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
well they're the fact that Hillary is
not Bernie doesn't mean that Hillary is
Trump and that has never been more clear
than after hearing this this should wake
some people up okay maybe things won't
change on Wall Street maybe things won't
change in the baking industry yeah maybe
things won't even really change that
much in terms of foreign policy right
but at least there won't be nuclear
exchanges this this really sounds like
an individual who is disturbed and
clueless to a degree that we haven't
seen for a while and and Louis and I
received some tweets Rachel people
asking do we think that a psych eval
should sort of be standard for anyone
who is a major party nominee and this is
the type of thing that makes me say yes
there it should be standard I definitely
think there should be and I also think
that in terms of kind of everything he's
saying about nuclear nuclear war and
nuclear weapons is that okay well now
I'm just gonna further align myself with
Putin as well and just kind of showing
this showing this type of arrogant
belligerent yeah what do we make of that
that is fascinating we've been talking
about this possible link between Trump
and Russia and Putin what is more
belligerent and arrogant and Putin like
than saying problems nukes those are the
solutions if ever Trump has sounded more
like Putin it is this type of thing it
actually is probably an insult to Putin
this probably goes beyond Putin to some
degree well if Trump were to become
president what would be the difference
between him and Putin I mean Putin rides
on horses shirtless and does judo Trump
rides in his cop in his chopper yeah but
they're both rich white guys who seem to
be incredibly arrogant and full of
themselves you remember Katrina Pierson
this is the Trump spokeswoman who said
incorrectly that Donald Trump's Muslim
ban never singled out Muslims defended
the call for a pure-breed president
defended the Muslim ban by saying so
what they're Muslim and also appeared on
CNN wearing a bullet necklace she went
on CNN yesterday to talk about this
horrible PR nightmare Oh
Donald Trump slamming the Goldstar
parents of the deceased US Army captain
Humayun Kahn and she went with the
strategy of blame Obama no matter what
this was an interview yesterday with
Wolf Blitzer
I was I was Louis at the gym on the
elliptical and I almost flew off the
elliptical when I when I saw this
because it was so crazy blame Obama for
a military death in 2004 do some math
you might remember Trump became
president and I'm sorry whoa big
Freudian slip Obama became president in
January of 2009 take a look at this
thought on the battle prevented some of
his fellow soldiers from dying by going
into that suicide that car bombing if
you will I'm not going to get into a
discussion of back and forth I praise
this family I praise the Sun and move on
he didn't have to go back and forth and
respond to all of the but surely you can
understand the confusion
considering how Donald Trump never voted
for the Iraq war Hillary Clinton did and
then she didn't support the troops to
have what they need it was under Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton that changed
the rules of engagements that probably
cost his life so I don't understand why
it's so hard to understand why Donald
Trump was confused not why he was being
held responsible for something he had
nothing to do with while Hillary Clinton
had everything to do it
wait-wait-wait-wait-wait President Obama
who became president in 2009 and Hillary
Clinton who was his Secretary of State
after that same date are responsible for
changing the rules and of engagement
such that an individual member of the
military died in 2004 what was President
Obama doing in 2004 it was certainly not
changing the rules of engagement this is
what we call a straw man the cons aren't
holding Donald Trump responsible for
their son's death they're holding Donald
Trump responsible for his bigoted
statements his blatantly
unconstitutional proposals his his
inconsiderate response to their
statements as grieving parents and
somehow Katrina Pierson Louis says Obama
and Clinton are to blame for the death
of this individual five years before
the president became the president yeah
it makes no sense but I don't even
understand the point of bashing Obama at
this point now bash Hillary that seems
to be a more effective campaign strategy
that was confusing to me the bash Obama
what is that what do you gain from
bashing Obama now well Obama well first
of all Republicans have history of kind
of blaming Democrats for things that had
absolutely nothing to do with them and
Obama was blamed for Isis when Bush kind
of clearly planted that seed when he
voted and instituted the Iraq war yeah
that's not a new thing and I'm actually
starting to think that even though
Republicans are the anti-science party
they must believe in time travel because
that's the only way half of these
accusations make sense right or they're
really bad at math well absolutely
they're about it man there's no if there
Louis I mean naive Rachel thinks it's
possible Republicans might be bad at
math they're bad at math but somehow
masters at manipulating statistics yeah